sometimes and it often happens in bed we
face an acute test at the hands of a
lover to whom we have pledged our
affections we are asked with little
warning and maybe in a serious tone what
do you love me for few moments in a
relationship can be as philosophical as
this or as dangerous the good answer has
the power to confirm and enhance a
relationship a bad one could blow it
apart as we try to make headway we
immediately recognize that we can't
simply say everything we're being asked
to make choices and our love will be
deemed sincere to the extent that these
choices feel accurate to their
recipients the fundamental assumption
behind the inquiry is that there are
better and worse things to be loved for
it isn't a brute fact that we are liked
that can count the liking has to target
certain of our best characteristics as
we define these which in turn implies
that there are parts of our minds and
our bodies that feel as though they
better contain our essential selves than
others we are if we can put it like this
not equally present in all parts of
ourselves when it comes to the body
there appears to be more of us in our
hands than in our heels and when it
comes to the mind more of us in our
sense of humor than in our knowledge of
the 7 times table if a malevolent demon
were to force us to give up a bit of our
minds it might be better from the point
of view of maintaining the continuity of
our essential selves to surrender our
ability to speak a foreign language
rather than to wipe out our taste in
music just as it would be more bearable
to suffer a change in the shape of our
big toe than in the profile of our nose
to be told that we have a lovable mind
maybe a good start but not much more
there are likely to be many things that
this mind can do quite well lay a table
Drive Safely down a motorway prepare a
household budget remember geographical
facts
but such talents seldom feel gratifying
when singled out because of their rather
generic nature someone who loved us for
these skills alone would have few
reasons why they might not equally well
wander away and love someone else at
another point which is the very risk we
are trying to ward off and are looking
for the right complement to appears the
skills it's touching to be praised for
are those in which some of our
uniqueness can be observed for example
in the way we prepare the icing of a
birthday cake or pick songs for a drive
through the desert or analyze a
historical novel discuss a friend's love
affair or likely teased a frustrating
colleague without ruffling their dignity
if someone has started to notice such
details then he or she starts to feel
like a reliable candidate to whom to get
attached their love has become specific
rather than generic it is in the end a
good deal more gratifying for a lover to
pay us a small compliment about the deft
way we're able to dislodge your relative
from a sulk than to be declared a
sensational human for knowing the
capital of New Zealand all the way to
calculate the diameter of a circle but
to add further complexity to our demands
it isn't enough just to be admired we
also want a true lover to feel well
disposed towards our vulnerabilities
whatever our degree of competence we are
never far from moments of fear ignorance
humiliation child likeness and sadness
and it is these moods too that we long
for a lover to have the strength to feel
generous towards it may be pleasant to
be found impressive but it's more
reassuring to discover that our
vulnerability is ready to be treated
with generosity that we are with someone
who will allow us to be sad discomforted
and weepy who was spotted that we
sometimes bite our nails or worry about
our work late at night we don't bluntly
want to or a lover we want permission to
be every now and then at wit's end we
want them to have sufficient faith in
our power that they can be unfrozen by
our periods of fragility
we need to know that the child in us has
been seen and won't appalled I love you
for being such a hero would be an eerie
pronouncement I love you for being a
child would be equally alienating but
something like I love the sad child I
occasionally glimpse in you beneath your
resourceful adult day-to-day self well
that comes as close as one can imagine
to the epicentre of love our hopes for
what role our body will play in
eliciting love follow a comparable
pattern here - sweeping generic praise
feels like the work of someone who might
not notice if our body was replaced by
that of another in the night it might be
true that we have lovely eyes or soft
hair but exactly the same words could be
said with accuracy - millions of others
just as a host would not want to hear
thanks for a nice dinner but rather
praise for that hint of dill in the
lemon sauce some of the best kinds of
praise about the body are psychophysical
that is they praise a physical aspect in
order to highlight a psychological
quality they reassure us that our
physical envelopes have been connected
up with the most lovable sides of our
personalities so a perceptive lover
might say I really like the way your
smile is slightly different on each side
of your mouth you see one side is warm
and welcoming and the other is sort of
thoughtful and a bit melancholy you're
not really smiling it seems like you're
thinking deeply as you smile or what
about this there's a charming thing you
do with your eyelids when you're
listening half bringing them down in a
quizzical way if it's like you're saying
I don't totally believe you but it's
really an encouragement there's an
invitation as if you were adding but
come on give me the real truth I know
you're holding back the best bits
because you worry you won't be
understood but you will be you're safe
with me
or I'm slightly in love with that
freckle on your upper left arm it's a
bit like you quietly saying Here I am I
me nothing special but I'm happy with
who I am it's poised and unsure but
confident of its power to attract those
who get it
I loved that it was there when you were
little and that it's been with you every
day since we can add that just as with
the mind it is frequently vulnerability
in bodily details that charms it is the
little toe and the little finger that
seduced more than the thighs or the
thorax it is the hand that curls up as
it must have done in childhood it is the
thin nape of the neck normally hidden
behind a confident mane of hair it is a
delicate wrist through which run
intricate greenish veins within an
otherwise mature body we're seeing hints
of an endearing and more fragile earlier
self to whom we offer our sympathy
protection and reassurance the question
of what we have found to love in someone
should not frighten us we simply need to
give ourselves the time to trace back
our enthusiasms to their authentic
sources while remembering that love is
liable to collect with particular
intensity in the most vulnerable and
improbably small nooks of the self our
pillow-talk cards help prompt us to
share our intimate desires to find out
more follow the link on your screen now
you